des flammes gigantesques ont ravagé
l'intérieur du parlement sur la façade
des inscriptions anti gouvernementales à
l'origine de la colère l'adoption cette
semaine du budget 2021 par le congrès
non loin de là au moment de cet incendie
se tenait une manifestation pacifique
devant l'ancien palais du gouvernement
dans le centre historique de la capitale
nous sommes fatigués parce que le pays
s'endette et on ne peut plus rien
tolérée lors de ce samedi de
mobilisation une vingtaine de personnes
ont été interpellées par la police
les forces de l'ordre qui ont lancé des
gaz lacrymogènes sur la foule malgré la
présence d'enfants ces centaines de
guatémaltèques exigent la démission du
président alejandro jam était à la tête
du pays depuis à peine dix mois pour les
protestataires le chef de l'état est
coupable d'avoir donné son aval au
budget contreversé de près de 13
milliards de dollars voté au congrès un
budget qui génère la dette la plus
importante de l'histoire du guatemala
le vice président du pays lui-même
exhortent le président à démissionner
comme on dit là j'ai dit très clairement
au président que les choses n'allaient
pas bien sûr de nombreuses questions
gouvernementales et que je ne suis pas
d'accord avec les décisions qui ont été
prises
je n'ai pas été consulté sur ces
questions en raison du manque de
communication que nous avons avec le
président c'est aussi dû à une demande
des citoyens pourront nous a dit que les
choses n'étaient pas comme les gens
l'espérer la population déçue de voir ce
budget 2021 destinée surtout à financer
des infrastructures gérées par des
entrepreneurs parlant même de corruption
pour les manifestants le gouvernement
néglige les défis prioritaires
six habitants sur 10
vivent dans la pauvreté au guatemala et
la malnutrition infantile touche près de
la moitié des enfants de moins de cinq
ans